this is a survey student loan
forgiveness recipient 73 percent of
applicants say they are likely to spend
their extra money on non-essential
including vacations smartphone drugs and
alcohol they admitted that to the
pollster
who is this poster I uh
NBC News
52 they are very likely or likely to buy
new clothing 46 they would use the money
for vacation and eat out at restaurants
this is why people have a thing about I
would never call it free money oh I
guess they just did they don't
understand basic human psychology they
just like the very thin veneer the very
thin veneers we'd like to help these
people and these people that I assume
it's a lot of minorities and the
lesbians and the people with one leg and
we've got to help them but if you don't
think that Bernie is a fraud Beyond
human imagination Beyond imagination who
has no balls by the way Bernie you have
no balls either